tonight we're finally making progress
here with reaction the attorney that is
representing the FBI informant Victoria
tun Singh as well as the hills John
Solomon's circuit news as Sara kurta I'm
beginning to think you guys are the
Woodward and Bernstein of our time thank
you both for being here I know it's
taken a lot of courage on your part and
you've taken a lot of personal hits but
now the evidence is overwhelming
Victoria let's start with what we were
asking for last night has now come out
that in fact the NDA the non-disclosure
my guests come with props that's great
tell us what you got there well I have
the letter that you read the press
release that you tracked actually the
wording is the same in my letter it's
just to me and telling me to get in
contact with the FBI about process okay
so the process would be that the NDA
will be lifted and the informant and we
were told he knew in 2009 and 2010
before the uranium one deal was done
that he had overwhelming evidence that
he had emails that he had documents that
he has tapes that would show the bribery
the racketeering the corruption the want
money laundering and extortion is that
what we expect to hear yes and he can
put a lot of meat on those bones that
Sarah and John have built for us he can
give context and he can tell about
conversations the Russians had about
what they were doing with various piles
of money and the Iranian where did the
money come from Victoria a Russia I'm
not gonna get into that yet let's get in
this way - okay he tells us Sarah let's
go - you and John you guys have been
amazing on this I really give you guys a
lot of credit okay let's go to 2009 what
did the FBI know and why would people
like Robert Mahler the director of the
FBI at the time or rod Rosenstein who
was ahead in the best in the
investigation why would they have
ignored this and then also the
Department of Justice Eric Holder had to
know what the FBI had why would he ever
sign off on giving Putin 20% of our
uranium when the evidence shows he was
trying to corner the market here well I
certainly think Sean that what's going
to happen here is that this
investigation like Victoria said there's
going to be a lot more meat on these
and what we knew from now looking at the
documents back in 2009 they were well
aware of money laundering kickbacks
connected to the Russian uranium
industry and connected to firms here
inside what you know inside the United
States so one of the things that they're
going to be looking for is those
connections and where did that money go
and who they were bribing and how real a
national security threat was this I mean
was this just kind of covered up because
remember nobody back then actually knew
there was an ongoing investigation so it
was really up to the FBI from and the
informant the confidential informant
spent four years undercover and there it
was like four years before any charges
were brought against these players and
remember they were only bright against
these players very minor you know
charges and the exposure to these
companies was not made public so I think
right now
the House Intelligence Committee the
House Oversight Committee the Senate
Judiciary Committee and hopefully a
special counsel will look into this and
connect all of those I wanted to stay on
this and I promise we have plenty of
time tonight as you guys are here for a
while so for four years this FBI
informant Victoria's client worked
undercover and he discovered a network
if you will evidence that showed not
only did they use money laundering
kickbacks bribery extortion but that
they also had the evidence that this was
a network that was being built and
designed by Moscow and Vladimir Putin to
corner uranium market in this country he
knew that he knew that at the time is
that what you're saying
that'll influence and to peddle
influence with the State Department and
the Clintons alright first we'll go to
Sarah that will go to John Sarah yes I
mean one of the one of the biggest
issues was that Vladimir Putin wanted to
penetrate the u.s. uranium market as
well as our energy market this was a
huge deal for him he wanted to move this
through it was a main main point in all
of the things that he did and I think
that the informant who was privy to
these conversations who had recordings
had usually I was able to show that
those he stole I'm gonna leave that to
Victoria to answer Toria will let you
know well let you know what he has you
know i you've got a friend for years
you're so tough i try to be crazy but i
love you for it and I'd hire you in
twenty seconds because you're so good
alright John Solomon let's go to this
this issue this is a huge we have all
you go back it's two years since we
learned about uranium one Peter
Schweitzer will join us later you guys
have been digging and investigating now
for a long time
bit by bit you're putting this together
is this a network was it was Vladimir
Putin through agents trying to corner
the market and uranium and our FBI knew
about it and Eric Holder the head of the
the Attorney General the head of the
Department of Justice actually signed
off on this
well one of the things that today I
ordered up the transcript for the
sentencing hearing and there's an
amazing gap from a few months before
these guys pled out where the government
said we think this leads all the way to
Russia that the benefactors are in
Russia and that the people who
controlled the conspiracy and root were
in Russia and then when they got to the
sentencing here and they kind of
minimized it saying we really don't know
where the money went and the judge was
kind of incredulous saying what how
could you not know where the money's
going but one of the more important
things that they did say at the
sentencing was there's no doubt that
this compromised America's nuclear
security was no doubt that it was a
corrupt scheme that could have put
uranium in danger and so John let me ask
you so Bill Clinton gets twice as normal
speaking fees at Moscow at the time he's
asking his own life State Department to
get permission for him to meet with with
nuclear operatives in Russia people
involved in this sort of thing he didn't
then got to meet with Putin he's being
paid by a bank that has a financial
interest in uranium one meeting with
Putin wanting to talk to the nuclear
officials in Russia talks to Putin the
deal gets done but our government knew
about the bribery money laundering you
know call this other corruption they
knew about it the whole time how do you
possibly sign that deal and give
America's uranium away and so our
country security out there's no doubt
that the color of money that was raining
down during this parrot was noticeably
red it was coming from Moscow
I've been working on a project just
putting all the different monies that
came in from Russia it's over 40 million
dollars over a two three-year period
going to people around the clintons that
can't be an accident before they signed
off on uranium one I'm sorry son
40 million before they signed off on
where anyone well during the time when
you're anyone was being reviewed after
it was approved and while these new
nuclear commercial contracts that were
coming in from the utilities we're also
getting a nod from the Obama
administration it's a two three-year
window but it's a lot of money and
tomorrow or the next couple days we'll
be able to come on and lay out that
money path for you Sean don't forget my
client was being told by the FBI that
President Obama was being briefed on
this matter
wouldn't we know from his presidential
daily briefing we would we can we get
those John and Sarah I think I got a I
got a oh no time you're all staying so
don't go anywhere